lena fast 50 zu füttern nach 18 in
diesem moment wieder dieses leben nicht
losgegangen hier sie haben gerade
zweimal luftalarm gehört wie schon so
häufig in den vergangenen 16 tagen als
sie liebe zuschauer gehören sie ist
das sind die sie reden leid in diesem
moment um ihr
was die menschen hier in diesem moment
erleben müssen das ist ein moment der
vielen menschen wieder kann man sagen
angst macht neue angst macht deswegen
möchte ich über diktator lukaschenko
sprechen über den mann der belarus
regiert er dort ein diktator ist er dort
die wahlen verloren hatte aber an der
macht bleiben konnte sie hören weiterhin
im hintergrund die luft sie sehen hier
in kiew genau in diesem moment und
lukaschenko droht das ist das was wir
hören möglicherweise in diesen krieg mit
einzutreten das ist das was ukrainische
quellen sagen dass er in dieser nacht
und möglicherweise morgen zwei gruppen
richtung ukraine schicken könnte truppen
dann auch die hier wo ich sitze die
hauptstadt kiew weiter angreifen könnten
und lukaschenka hat sich dafür heute
lange mit wladimir putin in moskau
unterhalten sie sehen ich habe mich
schon ein bisschen dran gewöhnt an die
sirenen ich rede einfach mal weiter und
beim thema zu bleiben mit wladimir putin
getroffen und hat fast fünf stunden mit
ihnen gesprochen wir gehen davon aus
dass wladimir putin und das sind die
spekulation und das sind auch die
erkenntnisse die die ukrainische quellen
haben dass man lukas schenkel davon
überzeugen will dass seine armee kommt
ihr auch nach in die ukraine vor stößen
und dass er versuchen wird sozusagen
hier diesen krieg gemeinsam mit wladimir
putin gegen sie lenz gegen gesamte
ukraine zu besetzen
wenig wenn sie direkt darauf reagieren
und einmal auch für uns ihre sicht
analysieren auf die aktuelle lage
ja in der tat die lage bleibt sehr
angespannt in in kiew rund um die
hauptstadt auch in der gesamten ukraine
vor allem die städte im osten mariupol
da ist eine katastrophe die sich vor
unseren augen abspielt oder anderen
städten also cardiff auch der konsum
eine reihe von kleineren städten die
wirkliche fast schon platt gemacht
wurden von von den bomben und das zeigt
dass wahrscheinlich diese sanktionen die
ja eingeführt wurden und die wirkung
zeigen weil die wirtschaft in russland
schon im freien fall sich befindet aber
wahrscheinlich ist es noch nicht genug
der dieser druck musste weiterhin
verschärft werden und deswegen ist das
thema das schon seit tagen auf der auf
dem tisch liegt nämlich
importstopp für russische rohstoffe war
auch die deutsche
auch die gesellschaft hier eigentlich
sich hinter diesem gedanken gestellt
hatte über die mehrheit 55 prozent der
deutschen sind dafür sie werden bereits
auch diesen hohen preis zu zahlen und
der mieter kriegt zu ende geht und
deswegen sind wir enttäuscht dass die
bundesregierung nach wie vor zugute und
nicht diese entscheidung treffen kann
die amerikanische präsident joe biden
eine rückfrage der amerikanische
präsident joe biden hat ja heute
weiteren sanktionen zugestimmt sind die
genug haben sie damit gerechnet wie
stehen sie zu der heutigen entscheidung
job 1 und auch natürlich zu dem was er
gesagt hat es ist wichtig dass die
amerikaner hier auch diese listen zeigen
und die deutschen haben auch in den
letzten jahren immer wieder mit dem
finger gezeigt richtung washington
gesagt ja aber die kaufen auch immer
noch aus russland jetzt seit zwei tagen
ist das nicht mehr so und das heißt dann
müssten auch die deutschen endlich
mitziehen und auch diese führungskraft
zumindest hier in europa auf den tag
legen das ist das was man aus berlin
erwartet ich will mal was zu den
fernsehbildern sagen die wir hier aus
moskau gesehen haben lukaschenko und
putin sitzen direkt nebeneinander das
ist ein völlig anderes bild als das das
wir kennen als makro da waren und scholz
da waren die wurden auf distanz gehalten
wir können also jetzt erkennen es geht
überhaupt nicht corona wenig den pcr
test machen geht überhaupt nur weil die
haben auch nicht kontrolliert ob
lukaschenko den test gemacht hat das
geht überhaupt nicht um corona sondern
diese beiden makro und scholz sollten
gedemütigt werden und zwar schon rein
optisch auf distanz gehalten werden die
hat er nicht heran gelassen falls er
schröder getroffen hat den hatte
vermutlich noch am abend übrigens hat er
auch lukaschenka umarmt was man als
corona furcht mensch eigentlich nicht
tut wir sehen hier da fallen zwei welten
auseinander und ich muss sagen ich
wundere mich immer wieder wie
westeuropäische politiker glauben können
dass sie mit putin noch verlässliche
gespräche führen dass sie sich auf
irgendein wort von ihm verlassen können
für mich ist der mann verloren mit dem
kann man nicht mehr reden möglicherweise
gibt es eine art von psychologischer
beratung dass man ihn nicht ganz laufen
lassen soll man da dann richtig
gefährlich wird das mag sein aber
jedenfalls ich glaube auch nicht dass
jetzt die zeit der diplomatie ist die
ist noch nicht da das haben wir ja auch
bei den türkischen gesprächen gesehen
putin will erst mal militärisch gewinnen
ein kerl wie er muss gewonnen haben
bevor sie mit jemandem tisch setzt der
krieg wird noch einige zeit weitergehen
eine variante könnte die neutralität der
ukraine sein dass putin dann gewonnen
hat was halten sie davon herrn einig
dieser vorschlag ist jetzt auch den
letzten tagen kursiert ja dass darüber
hat man er spekulierte aber
es ist glaube ich noch zu früh auch
sogar darüber zu reden das kann nur auf
der höchsten ebene geschehen und so
lange es kein kein treffen gibt zwischen
meinen präsidenten salewski und herrn
putin es ist auch zu früh darüber auch
mal davor zu greifen dann natürlich
werden viele themen auf den tisch liegen
die besprochen werden müssen um dann
kriegst du zu beenden denn die
forderungen von putin wir sind ja in
ordnung sind und tomaten die da
verkündet wurden und das können wir
nicht akzeptieren aber natürlich in ihre
frage kann man auch möglichkeiten finden
um auch zu einem kompromiss zu kommen
mal sehen aber das könne nicht der
außenminister sagen das können nicht
andere unterhändler das können nur die
staatsoberhäupter tun und deswegen es
ist wichtig dass dieses gespräch so
schnell wie möglich zu stande kommen was
jetzt diskutiert wird hat putin doch
alles schon routine hat die krim putin
hat die ost ukraine wer will ihm da noch
irgendwas zu gestehen das ist faktisch
unter russischer kontrolle er will
offenbar noch eine landverbindung
zwischen der krim und der ost ukraine
herstellen deshalb leitet auch die stadt
mario pohl weil die liegt in der mitte
ich sehe das was dort passiert wie diese
ganze stadt zusammengeschlossen wird als
einen fall von ethnischer säuberung es
wird irgendwann auf gehen und dann
sollen die die ukraine gehen und die
russen kommen nach und auch die
neutralität der der ukraine ist auch
schon faktisch gegeben gewesen schon
durch den aufmarsch der russen als putin
und marcus scholz und packten mama kam
nach moskau haben sie putin gesagt also
die frage einer nato mitgliedschaft der
ukraine stellt sich gar nicht ich glaube
nicht da müsste schon sehr viel
passieren und die ukraine müsste quasi
über die russische armee triumphieren
dass sich putin auf dinge einlässt dir
schon längst hatte wollen wir ein paar
in die ich würde gern mal ja ich würde
gerne überall weil ich dann ein thema
aufgeworfen habe aber ich merke wenn ich
nicht im studio bin dann ist es
schwierig meint thema dort weil mir ging
es um lukas schenk und die frage was
sozusagen sein kriegseintritt sein
möglicher kriegseintritt bedeuten könnte
denn ich glaube zumindest in der ukraine
hat man das gefühl dass das ein weiterer
game changer sein könnte bislang wie
gesagt sind russische soldaten über die
grenze hier her aber wenn seine eigene
armee also die armee von lukaschenko
jetzt selbst mit in diesen krieg geht
das in diesen stunden genau die großen
sorgen die die ukraine zumindest haben
das ist das aktuellste und schwierigste
thema momentan mich würde da die sicht
von andrej melik interessieren wie sehr
das ganze sozusagen eine
eine schlechte nachricht ist für die
ukraine bzw wie schlimm das werden
könnte wenn sie jetzt auch noch lukas
schenk us-truppen an dem krieg
beteiligen
ja also die gefahr ist da und davon
wissen wir denn die das ist knapp 50.000
mann stark das heißt die darf man auch
nicht unterschätzen auch wenn die denn
wenn die technik vielleicht ein bisschen
verbreiteter ist als in russland aber
immerhin sind 50.000
truppen die womöglich jetzt über die
grenze auch vordringen können und
deswegen man hat sich schon darauf
vorbereitet aber das werde wenn es dazu
käme also dann da sondern wird auch
lukaschenko und auch das verhältnis zu
bill gross dass wir noch immer noch
versucht haben dann halt wechsel auf zu
erhalten dass das wäre dann quasi eine
rote linie wo es kein zurück mehr gibt
und auch hier musste sie können nicht
diesen krieg gewinnen das labor ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit wenig ich glaube sie
ist leider sie ist ziemlich hoch ist im
detail noch einmal sagen 60
über 50 prozent auf jeden fall seien die
beiden fünf stunden miteinander geredet
haben in einer kriegssituation und
dagegen sich um handelsfragen oder
ähnlich ist und dann ging es um ganz
entscheidende fragen offensichtlich dann
ist das ein ganz schlechtes zeichen aber
eine kriegsteilnahme von belarus wäre
auch ein ganz schlechtes zeichen für
putin erschafft es alleine nicht aus
meiner sicht ist dann das deutsche nein
zum import stopp für energie nicht mehr
zu halten dann wird der druck in der
deutschen gesellschaft überhaupt in
europa so groß werden dass sie das nicht
aushalten und dann werden wir das
bekommen was ich sowieso für richtig
halte und dann stehen wir vielleicht in
der eu etwas klarer auf der seite der
ukraine noch zum thema belarus ein
kurzer beitrag
wir haben ja jetzt über belarus
gesprochen wie bei ein mehr oder weniger
unabhängigen staat wir sollten aber
eines nicht vergessen es gab proteste
schon vor einem jahr als menschen
lukaschenko nicht wollten als oberhaupt
jetzt kürzlich gab es ein referendum
wollen belarus beschlossen wurde das
russische waffen bleiben sollen
inklusive atomwaffen das heißt
lukaschenko ist hier nicht jemand der
selbst entscheidet über irgendetwas er
ist putins man in belarus und wenn putin
den kriegseinsatz erhöhen will wird wäre
das auch durch lukaschenko tun das heißt
so noble die bemühungen der ukraine sind
auch ein gutes verhältnis zum belarus zu
erhalten es ist ganz klar dass der
mantel hier im hebels putin ist
ich finde das war ein sehr klares
statement am ende der debatte die
provinz hama hierauf geworfen hat wir
gehen damit weiter zum nächsten gedanken
darf ich die rollen noch eine frage
stellen
der residenz selensky hat heute von
einer strategischen wende in dem krieg
gesprochen was meint er damit
er meint so habe ich ihn verstanden die
bereitschaft so russland zu verhandeln
verkauf hat ja gesagt dass man
grundsätzlich nichts gegen verhandlungen
habe das war vorher mal ausgeschlossen
worden und genauso war ausgeschlossen
worden das seien es überhaupt der
präsident ist also das ist das was er
meinte möglicherweise ist das aber
überinterpretiert und auch bei der frage
wie entscheidend das jetzt für die
nächsten tage oder wochen wird denn wir
wissen ja wie viele finden putin in den
vergangenen monaten jahren jahrzehnten
schon geschlagen hat